hey this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning about article 5 of
the us constitution which describes the
constitution's amendment process
to learn more about article 5 i talked
to two experts professor michael
rappaport who is the darling foundation
professor at the university of san diego
school of law where he also serves as
the director of the center for the study
of constitutional originalism and david
strauss who's the gerald ratner
distinguished service professor of law
at the university of chicago law school
and author of the living constitution
professor strauss article 5
provides this process for amending the
constitution can you take us through
that process a little bit how does it
work
the quick description of the process is
it's really hard it's really hard to
amend the constitution
there are actually a couple of different
processes that are laid out in article 5
but
only one has ever been used
amendment starts in congress
and two-thirds of each house of congress
two-thirds of the house of
representatives
and two-thirds of the senate has to
approve the amendment
and then it goes to the states
and three quarters of the states have to
approve the amendment so you have to
have a really
strong consensus in order to get the
constitution changed that way
so professor rabapport take us through
this process of amending the
constitution
why did the framers set it up this way
the framers gave a good bit of thought
to coming up with an amendment process
because they recognized that the
constitution might need to be changed
over time either because there were
problems with it um that weren't
anticipated or because circumstances or
values changed so there are two steps to
the amendment process for an amendment
to go into the constitution to become
part of the constitution has to be both
proposed and ratified
on the proposal side
the congress can propose alternatively
a proposal
can come from the action of the state
legislatures so two-thirds of the state
legislatures say we'd like to have a
constitutional convention propose an
amendment so there's two parts of that
obviously the state legislatures have
got to want it and then you get the
calling of a constitutional convention
okay that's the proposal slide there's
also the ratification side which is a
little bit simpler
you need three quarters of the states to
ratify a constitutional amendment and
they can ratify it either through the
actions of the state legislatures or the
actions of
state conventions which are special
bodies which would be elected in order
to decide one question whether or not to
ratify that proposed constitutional
amendment this is fascinating so i i
actually had no idea about the the
two-thirds of the state legislatures
being able to propose a constitutional
amendment how often does that happen
it has never occurred throughout our
history although a couple of times there
were actions taken to sort of move in
that direction but we've never actually
had a a constitutional convention that
has proposed any any amendments it's
important to go into why the framers
would have set up the system the way
they did the most usual situation is for
the congress to propose
the amendments and that's happened in
all of the 27 amendments which have been
ratified for the become part of our
constitution but what happens if the
congress is the problem what happens if
the congress is doing is usurping power
or they're standing in the way of
changes that are important or they need
to be reformed you can't count on the
congress to want to reform itself so
what they did was to have this
alternative mechanism which would bypass
the congress and that alternative
mechanism was the the constitutional
convention so the state legislatures
propose uh
apply for it and then the
separate entity the constitutional
convention makes a proposal so they were
quite explicit in discussing this that
they wanted this as an alternative to
the congress so was this on purpose that
they made it very difficult to amend the
constitution
well it sure seems like it now of course
we don't know back then what they had in
mind whether they thought well the house
the senate the states they'll sort of be
all be run by the same kind of people
and they'll kind of agree on things
maybe they thought that we just don't
know but whatever they were thinking
what they gave us was a very difficult
process to get through
so how long was it from the period
when
the constitution was first ratified to
the first amendment to the constitution
beyond the bill of rights
okay so the the first 10 amendments were
were ratified in 1791
and
then just uh a mere three years later
we had the 11th amendment there was an
11th amendment in 1798 to correct really
really kind of a technical problem that
the
supreme court did something that the
framers really didn't anticipate it
would do didn't want it to do and the
11th amendment was adopted to to correct
that
the 12th amendment was adopted in 1804
after the
um really kind of a disaster in the
election of 1800 when there was a tie in
the electoral college the framers had
not foreseen the rise of political
parties and political parties made the
system for electing the president they
had given us very difficult to work with
but then there was nothing that was 1804
then there was nothing until after the
civil war and after civil war there were
three amendments then nothing again
really until the progressive era in the
early 20th century when they were again
a bunch of amendments and then after
then things have sort of paled off so we
really see these kind of as i said these
kind of waves in our history what do you
think brings those waves on why there
why are there some eras when there are
lots of constitutional amendments and
other eras when there's nothing
well come here i'm going to say
something i think some people will
disagree with but you know but i think
it's right
and that is that i don't think the
process of amending the constitution has
really been the way we actually change
it
i think what happens is
just because the amendment process is so
difficult
we've worked out other ways of changing
things
and so amendments come along
sometimes because a change has already
happened and people decide well let's
let's put in the constitution just so we
can kind of have official recognition of
it
but a lot of times changes happen and
there are a little bit too controversial
to get into the constitution but they
seem pretty solid and pretty secure
so we just don't don't i guess it's fair
to say don't bother to amend the
constitution or don't want to go through
the process of mending the constitution
very often people's values may change or
they may differ from from what's in the
constitution
and it it may take a time or
circumstances may they may finally um
occur that that crystallized this this
desire to to change the constitution and
all of a sudden the opportunity is there
and
people can suddenly pass a
constitutional amendment
it's only going to occur during certain
circumstances especially when there's
strong support for it
very interesting yeah so it's unlikely
that we're going to have
a constitutional amendment any time in
the near future
when was the last constitutional
amendment
so the the simple answer to that was in
1971 we got the 26th amendment that was
both proposed and then remarkably
in its all-time record uh proposed and
ratified in three months and eight days
and that was the the amendment that
guaranteed the right to vote of 18 year
old
ah right so sort of as a response to the
vietnam war
yes yes
but
there actually has been one
additional amendment the 27th amendment
right so why isn't that the most recent
one well here's the funny thing about it
the the 27th amendment was proposed as
part of the original bill of rights in
so this amendment was proposed in 1789
ratified in 1992 so it took 202 years
interesting and what's the 27th
amendment about
that has to do with uh congressional
salary increases it basically says if
congress wants to raise its own salary
the increase can't take effect until the
next election so it basically gives the
voters a chance to to say hey we don't
like what you did we're going to vote
you out of office um for increasing your
salary
so one thing that strikes me about
article five and just the fact that the
the founders included an amendment
process altogether it seems very
humble and farsighted to
include a way for the document itself
to evolve
in a way do you think that the framers
approached the constitution with the
idea that there were things in the
future that they just wouldn't be able
to anticipate
they had before them
and were acutely aware of a history in
which efforts to establish governments
had failed and they were really
they were really trying to work with
that and make sure they didn't
do the same thing so they knew what a
hard
job they were embarking on
and there they made it clear there's a
famous passage in which james madison
said look we know a lot of these
provisions
that we're writing in the constitution
their meaning is unclear
and their meaning will have to be his
phrase was liquidated which is to say
people have to figure out what this
means because
we know what we're giving you is unclear
in some ways so yes absolutely they knew
there were things that they could not
anticipate
the framers themselves weren't in
agreement on what freedom of speech
means you know some of them enacted
voted for and got into got enacted
laws that restricted speech in ways that
we would find untol intolerable today
we'd say they violate the first
amendment
but here you had some of the guys who
drafted the first amendment voting for
those laws so near the end of article
five there's this kind of
long-winded clause that says no
amendment which may be made prior to the
year
1808 shall in any manner affect the
first and fourth clauses in the ninth
section of the first article now if i'm
cross-referencing this correctly what
they're really saying here is you can't
make any amendments about slavery so why
is this here and why are they talking
around it so obliquely the interesting
thing about this is what did they do
they basically said for 20 years there's
not going to be any amendments that are
going to speak to the slave trade and
the the constitution is is uh very let's
let's say shy
about using
the term
slavery or referring to slavery it
actually
never
actually refers to the term slave
there's a variety of
thoughts about what was going on but but
but one very common uh view about this
is that the the constitution was sort of
um a little bit embarrassed that the
framers were a little bit embarrassed or
at least some of the framers were
embarrassed about it um and so they
didn't want to make reference to it too
explicitly they might have been a little
bit worried about what the verdict of
history would be so so they they knew on
some level the sort of immorality of
slavery but uh but there it is right
there in article five and there are
other places in the constitution too
where they don't use the word but what
they're doing is protecting slavery now
they did have these amendments to the
constitution
about slavery and about as you say equal
citizenship and voting
but you know the the 14th amendment
providing equal citizenship that was
pretty much nullified in most respects
for a large part of our history
states found a way to get around that
the 15th amendment was also something
that was just not very effective in in
preventing african-americans from being
denied the vote
and yes there's uh there are provisions
in the constitution that are there and
you can invoke them and you can rely on
them but if you just look at the text of
the constitution i think you get a
misleading impression about how the
constitution
in our history has actually worked
now this is a very good point because i
think one of the hardest things for
students of us history to understand is
how is it possible that after the 14th
amendment was passed things like jim
crow happened
and i guess the answer is
the constitution
is only in force
if it's enforced
it kim that's exactly right it's words
on a page you know that the text is fine
it can say all the right things but the
institutions and the popular popular
will have to be in place
to make something of those fine words
interesting so how do you think our
government might be different if the
constitution didn't include this
amendment process
i don't think it would have been that
different
just because
article 5 gives us such a hard process
to go through just because it's so hard
to amend the constitution we figured out
other ways
to change the constitution in practice
even if the words on the page are the
same and i think if there were no
article five
we would have found a way
to get to where we wanted to get to as a
country
by those means by legislation by
presidential action by supreme court
decision and just by the people in their
lives saying you know we we need to we
need to go in this direction we need to
go say in the direction of women's
equality and by the way there's no
amendment giving women equal rights
either but that's where we've gotten to
and i think that would have been the
pattern if there were no formal
amendment process
there's a second way in which you could
have constitutional change which is you
could simply say all right this
constitution
was pretty good for a while it's now
outlived its usefulness let's have a new
constitution that would seem like a very
radical big thing to do no one virtually
no one proposes that at the federal
level but in the states lots of states
have changed their constitutions not
simply past the constitutional amendment
but just gotten rid of the whole old
constitution and adopted a new one
that's happened many times and so if we
didn't have a constitutional amendment
process it's quite possible that that's
exactly what we would have seen at the
federal
level
yeah this is really fascinating because
we really think a lot about what the
framers intended you know for certain
amendments for example you know freedom
of speech freedom of religion what did
they really mean by those things
but if we had just kind of every now and
again said okay we're done with that
let's do a new constitution we wouldn't
necessarily have that debate we just say
okay this is what we meant at the time
famously thomas jefferson said oh you
know it's really not right to have a
constitution that's going to continue
over time
and bind future generations
and so we ought to have a new
constitution every 19 years when there's
a new generation
and his close friend james madison had
to disagree with him
and basically said look i i understand
why you're saying that but you also have
to realize the incredible disruption
that would cause
um every 20 years people wouldn't be
able to rely on the existing rights that
are in the constitution because they
would know in in a certain period of
time new ones would um
be enacted we had that debate madison
won in the sense that the u.s
constitution is is supposed to last for
a long term period there's no no 20-year
limit on it and one of the things that's
been beneficial for the united states as
a result of that is that we've inherited
these constitutional rights that people
have a lot of reverence for
so we've learned that there are two ways
to amend the constitution through
congress or through a special
constitutional convention called by the
states
either way adding an amendment to the
constitution is really difficult to do
so much so that the american people have
only in special circumstances used a
constitutional amendment to affect
social or political change to learn more
about article 5 visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics